thanks for being here Steve let's start
with this I think the world's biggest
problem is that people don't believe in
themselves what do you think and how do
we solve this problem
I agree Evan that a lack of self-belief
is a significant issue the most powerful
way to address this problem is to help
people develop a growth mindset a growth
mindset encourages individuals to see
challenges as opportunities for growth
and Improvement rather than as
insurmountable obstacles to foster a
growth mindset it's essential to change
the way we approach failures and
setbacks instead of viewing them as
indicators of our limitations we need to
treat them as valuable learning
experiences
by doing so people can gradually build
self-confidence and resilience which
will Empower them to believe in their
own abilities to dive deeper it's
crucial to promote an environment where
taking risks and making mistakes are not
just tolerated
but actively encouraged
this approach helps people understand
that failure is a natural part of the
learning process and that it's not
something to be feared through this
mindset individuals will be more
inclined to push their boundaries learn
from their experiences and ultimately
believe in themselves more
how do we create that environment of
risk taking and encouragement when most
people aren't in an environment where
the people around them are living in
scarcity negativity and fear especially
today
creating an environment that Fosters
risk-taking and encouragement despite
being surrounded by negativity and fear
can be challenging
the most powerful way to achieve this is
by becoming a source of positivity and
inspiration for others
to do this you should lead by example
show those around you that it's possible
to face challenges and take risks with
optimism and determination
share your own experiences of overcoming
adversity and learning from failures
demonstrating that growth can emerge
from these situations
in addition try to gradually change the
conversations within your environment
encourage discussions about
possibilities opportunities
and growth instead of focusing on
negativity and limitations you can share
stories of successful Risk Takers and
the lessons they have learned inspiring
others to adopt a similar mindset by
embodying the qualities you wish to see
in others and actively promoting a
growth mindset you can gradually
influence the environment around you it
may take time and persistence but your
positive attitude and commitment to
personal growth can Inspire others to
adopt a similar Outlook eventually
creating a more supportive and
encouraging environment
I feel a little more hopeful already
just talking with you I'm glad to hear
that Evan it's important to remember
that change starts with a single person
and by being a positive influence you
can make a difference in the lives of
those around you
keep believing in yourself and Inspire
others to do the same the more we Foster
a growth mindset and create an
environment of encouragement the more
people will believe in themselves and
their potential
how do we stay motivated to be that
single person who makes a difference to
stay motivated as the single person
making a difference it's vital to focus
on your personal connection to the
impact you want to create
this emotional connection will keep you
driven and inspired even during
challenging times
take time to reflect on the lives you
wish to touch and the change you want to
see in the world
visualize the difference you can make
and how it aligns with your values and
aspirations by consistently connecting
to the emotional aspect of your purpose
you'll find the motivation and
determination to persevere and make a
difference embracing this deep
connection to your purpose will not only
provide a sense of fulfillment but it
will also act as a guiding force helping
you navigate challenges and stay focused
on the impact you want to create
so what's your purpose Steve my purpose
has always been to create products that
enrich people's lives and make a dent in
the universe I've been passionate about
combining technology with Art and Design
to create user-friendly Innovative and
aesthetically pleasing devices
I believe that technology should Empower
individuals making their lives easier
and more enjoyable by challenging the
status quo and pushing the boundaries of
what's possible I've sought to
revolutionize the way people interact
with technology and in turn the way they
experience the world this purpose has
driven me throughout my career and has
been at the core of everything I've done
at Apple and Beyond
other days when you just get too tired
when the mission just feels too big that
it's not possible and that you're
fighting against everyone
absolutely there were days when I felt
overwhelmed and exhausted when it seemed
like the mission was too big or that I
was fighting an uphill battle
I'm only human and like everyone else I
had my moments of doubt and weakness but
in those moments I would remind myself
of my purpose
and the impact I wanted to create I
would think about the people whose lives
would be changed by the products and
ideas we were working on this would help
me find the motivation and strength to
keep going it's also important to
remember that no one can achieve great
things alone having a strong team of
like-minded and talented individuals
supporting you can make all the
difference
they can help carry the weight of the
mission and work together to overcome
obstacles making this seemingly
impossible possible who was that person
for you who lifted you up when you felt
overwhelmed there were several people
who played a significant role in
supporting me during my journey but one
person who stands out is Steve Wozniak
my co-founder at Apple was was not only
a brilliant engineer but also a close
friend
we shared a passion for technology and a
vision for what it could become our
partnership was built on Mutual trust
and respect
was had the technical expertise to bring
my ideas to life and we complemented
each other's strengths when I felt
overwhelmed waz's optimism Ingenuity and
dedication to our shared goals would
help lift me up and reignite my
motivation it's crucial to have someone
like that in your life a partner friend
or Mentor who shares your passion and
can support and encourage you when times
are tough having that kind of connection
and support can make all the difference
in overcoming challenges and staying
true to your mission
how about any habits or rituals that
made a difference for you to keep you on
track
significant difference for me was my
daily routine of reflection and
mindfulness I practiced Zen meditation
for many years and it helped me develop
a sense of focus and Clarity allowing me
to approach challenges with a calm and
collected mindset meditation provided me
with the space to clear my thoughts
reflect on my purpose and reconnect with
my inner self this practice enabled me
to maintain perspective during
challenging times and stay grounded
amidst the chaos that often comes with
running a company like Apple
incorporating mindfulness into my daily
routine allowed me to stay focused on my
goals make better decisions and keep my
energy directed towards what truly
mattered this habit was crucial in
helping me stay on track and maintain my
drive to make a difference
can you walk us through how you did your
Zen meditation certainly Zen meditation
also known as zazen is a form of
meditation that emphasizes focused
awareness and mindfulness here's a
simple outline of how I practiced Zen
meditation find a quiet space choose a
calm and quiet place where you can sit
undisturbed this will help you focus and
minimize distractions sit comfortably
you can sit cross-legged on a cushion or
mat or use a chair if that's more
comfortable the key is to maintain a
straight posture with your spine aligned
and your head upright hand position
place your left hand on top of your
right hand Palms up with your thumbs
gently touching each other forming a
circle rest your hands on your lap close
to your body close your eyes or maintain
a soft gaze you can either close your
eyes or keep them slightly open with a
soft gaze directed downwards at a 45
degree angle pay attention to your
breath as it moves in and out of your
body feel the sensation of your breath
in your nostrils chest or abdomen this
will help anchor your attention and keep
you focused as thoughts arise simply
acknowledge them without judgment and
let them go gently bring your focus back
to your breath each time your mind
wanders start with a short duration like
five or ten minutes and gradually
increase the length of your meditation
sessions over time as you become more
comfortable Zen meditation is about
being present and fully aware of the
current moment
by practicing regularly you can develop
greater mental Clarity focus and a sense
of inner peace that can help you
navigate the challenges of everyday life
that was awesome I never thought I'd get
a detailed meditation lesson with Steve
Jobs I'm glad you found it helpful Evan
meditation has been an essential part of
my life and I believe it can bring many
benefits to others as well what do you
think of everything that's happening
with AI right now
I think the advancements in AI are
incredibly exciting and have the
potential to revolutionize various
Industries and aspects of our daily
lives
the ability for machines to learn
analyze data and make decisions has come
a long way and the possibilities seem
endless however with such powerful
technology comes a great responsibility
it's important for developers and
companies to consider the ethical
implications and potential impact of AI
on society
we must strive to create AI systems that
align with human values and principles
ensuring that these Technologies are
used for the greater good as we continue
to push the boundaries of AI I believe
we should maintain a focus on improving
people's lives and solving real world
problems by keeping the user experience
in ethical considerations at the
Forefront we can ensure that AI
Innovations lead to a better more
connected world
if you were in charge of an AI company
what would you be doing differently
if I were in charge of an AI company my
main focus would be on prioritizing user
experience
I believe that technology should be
designed with the end user in mind and
AI is no exception
by creating intuitive user-friendly
applications that seamlessly integrate
into people's lives we can ensure that
AI Technologies are accessible engaging
and truly beneficial to achieve this I
would invest in a deep understanding of
users needs preferences and behaviors
this would involve conducting extensive
research user testing and feedback
analysis to continuously refine and
improve our AI products
by empathizing with users and
maintaining a strong focus on there's
their experience we can create AI
solutions that not only solve real world
problems but also resonate with the
people who use them in addition
fostering a design-centric culture
within the company would be crucial this
would encourage the team to approach AI
development with a creative and
human-centered mindset ensuring that our
Technologies are not just functional but
also delightful and meaningful to the
users
by putting user experience at the
Forefront we can build AI technologies
that truly make a positive impact on
people's lives
you talk a lot about user experience is
that part of the secret sauce that made
Apple so successful yes user experience
has always been a crucial part of
Apple's secret sauce
we believe that technology should not
only be functional but also beautiful
intuitive and enjoyable to use
our focus on user experience set us
apart from other tech companies and
played a significant role in Apple's
success at Apple we were deeply
committed to understanding our users
needs and desires we invested time and
resources in creating products that not
only solve problems but also delighted
and inspired people we paid attention to
every detail from Hardware design and
software interface to packaging and
customer service
by prioritizing user experience and
blending it with Cutting Edge technology
and design we were able to create
products that stood out in the market
and resonated with users on an emotional
level
this approach helped us build a loyal
customer base and a strong brand
identity
Paving the way for Apple's success over
the years
this might sound a little basic but for
entrepreneurs who want to make user
experience part of their secret sauce
what should they keep in mind for
entrepreneurs looking to make user
experience part of their secret sauce
the key is to empathize with your users
and understand their needs preferences
and pain points keep the following
principle in mind put yourself in the
user's shoes get to know your target
audience intimately conduct research
user testing and gather feedback to gain
insights into their behaviors
motivations and expectations
by deeply understanding your users
you'll be able to identify opportunities
for improvement and Innovation that
cater to their needs
focus on creating products and services
that are not only functional but also
aesthetically pleasing and enjoyable to
use
consider every aspect of the user
experience from the interface and
interactions to the physical design and
packaging
strive to make the experience as
seamless intuitive and delightful as
possible user experience is an ongoing
process continuously iterate and refine
your products based on user feedback and
testing
be open to making changes and
improvements to better meet the needs of
your users and stay ahead of the
competition
by keeping these principles in mind and
making user experience a core part of
your company's culture you can create
products that resonate with your target
audience build a loyal customer base and
set your brand apart in the market
any advice for how I can do this from my
YouTube channel to apply the principles
of user experience to your YouTube
channel consider the following
understand your audience
get to know your viewers and their
preferences look at your Channel's
analytics read comments and engage with
your community to understand what
resonates with them
identify their interests needs and pain
points to tailor your content
accordingly create engaging content
focus on producing high quality
informative and entertaining videos that
align with your audience's interests
make sure your videos are well
structured visually appealing and easy
to follow use clear and concise language
to communicate your message effectively
optimize presentation pay attention to
the visual elements of your channel such
as thumbnails channel art and video
intros these elements should be visually
appealing consistent with your brand and
accurately represent the content of your
videos this helps attract viewers and
gives them a sense of what to expect
from your Channel
be responsive and interactive engage
with your audience through comments
social media and other platforms respond
to questions and feedback and show
appreciation for their support this
helps build a strong Community around
your channel and deepens your
understanding of your audience
continuously improve regularly review
your Channel's performance and user
feedback identify areas for improvement
and adjust your content strategy
accordingly stay up to date with Trends
and best practices to ensure that your
channel remains relevant and engaging by
focusing on user experience and applying
these principles to your YouTube channel
you can create a more engaging and
enjoyable experience for your viewers
which can lead to increased loyalty
growth and success all right I've got
some homework to do Steve thank you for
joining us here today do you have a
final message you'd like to share with
my audience of entrepreneurs who want to
change the world thank you for having me
Evan my final message to your audience
of entrepreneurs is this this
never lose sight of your passion and the
reason why you embarked on this journey
be driven by your vision and your desire
to make a difference in the world
Embrace challenges take risks and learn
from your failures surround yourself
with people who share your passion who
Inspire and support you remember that
great things are achieved by those who
have the courage to think differently
and challenge the status quo stay
focused on creating products and
services that truly resonate with people
and always prioritize user experience by
doing so you'll not only build a
successful business but you'll also have
a lasting impact on the lives of your
customers in the world
hey this is real Evan Carmichael and I'd
love to know your thoughts on this video
did you like it did you not like it do
you want me to ask AI Steve Jobs other
questions do you want me to have other
people on historical figures and do an
interview with them I'd love to know
your thoughts please put it down in the
comments below if you want to see the
last top 10 I did on Steve Jobs check
the video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there he's considered the
father of the digital Revolution a
master of innovation and a design
perfectionist he had a net worth of over
8 billion dollars in 2010